good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
be seated we're ready to proceed thank
you all for being here on time we did
clear up a few minor legal matters so
we're ready to proceed with the
continued cross-examination of dr hassan
officer can you bring dr hassan in
please thank you
hi doctor welcome back
i'm going to ask you to remain standing
because we had a break we're going to
re-swear you you've been through this
before i can see that raise your right
hand please listen do you so in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth do
please state your nameless by your last
name for the record my name is charles s
hassan
all right doctor be seated
mr shellhorn
you may continue your cross-examination
thank you judge
good afternoon doctor good afternoon
i think uh where we left off yesterday
was asking you some questions about the
dsm
uh would you agree with me that there's
no diagnosis in the dsm that's
dispositive of any legal standard
i don't know about that
i doubt it
because
psychiatric
diagnoses
and legal standards are two separate
domains
so they may not uh overlap
so meaning that if you find or diagnose
someone with a specific diagnosis that
doesn't automatically mean they need
illegals well first of all i spelled out
in my report in a lot of detail
that when you're doing a report you have
to determine the reported
forensic report the purported intent of
the action then what you have to do is
to link the important and the purported
intent with the diagnosis those two then
the third step is to take those two
factors the diagnosis report ported
intent and then related
to
either diminished capacity or a criminal
responsibility so if you skip
the steps rather than getting you know
do step one or step two you have to do
all three so
it's uh
to answer you directly
unless you spell it out there's no
set
standard for a relationship between
diagnosis and the legal standard
meaning that just because you diagnose
someone with delusional disorder it
doesn't automatically mean they need a
legal standard i think on page 25 of
your book they point out the fact that
these are the steps you have to do you
have to relate the diagnosis to some
kind of functional deficit relate the
functional deficit to the diagnosis
so i think you're saying that you agree
with me i don't know what you i'm sorry
to say this way but i'm not sure i fully
understand what you're you're you're
thinking if you if you die and maybe
just try answering my question
diagnosis does not necessarily mean that
it meets a particular standard you have
to demonstrate
according to dsm 5
the steps along the way how you went
from
the
purported intent
the diagnosis those two factors and then
related to the legal statute
so if someone is diagnosed with
delusional disorder it doesn't
automatically mean that they meet a
legal standard
correct you have to demonstrate the
connection that's stated clearly in the
dsm-5
now you uh were aware of dr simran's
diagnosis before you rendered your
opinion
uh yes
and you agreed with him that this
defendant suffers from delusional
disorder persecutory type yes
you would agree that a person with
delusions is capable of knowing right
versus wrong it depends on the situation
because
um paranoid delusions
is a dimension and i said the other day
it goes from normal population into
very disturbed people so it depends on
what part of that normal curve you're
talking about
you'd agree with me that a person with
delusions could understand the nature
and quality of their actions you totally
have to spell that out a lot more it
depends on the circumstance there's not
like a
black or white type of delusional
disorder
there's dimensionality here
doctor how do you define a delusion
i i mentioned the other day it's a
a belief
based on incorrect thinking basically
there's an experience then there's a
belief
based on incorrect thinking that comes
to a conclusion that the person is not
going to change no matter what kind of
argument you give so it's a thought that
was produced
incorrectly i gave examples
when i interviewed
mr barrissone of the
odd thinking that he had
and i thought it was an unusual you know
finding but then i say that um
some other people completely independent
of me but on a much higher level
have observed the same thing with
regards to delusions that it's a
cognitive processing difficulty someone
from um university of hawaii has written
extensively on that but i didn't know
that before i observed those behaviors
in him
so would you agree with me that a
delusion is a false belief it's a false
belief yes
what is michael barisson's specific
delusion
um well i touched on it yesterday and
instead of fireworks
he felt he believes that if he was he or
mary haskins was
incarcerated for
some purported dsm
excuse me some purported deifes
violation
that the children were going to be
hunted down and killed
he felt that very strongly
i don't believe that but you know
so his specific delusion
i'm sorry to interrupt thank you
so his specific delusion
in your opinion
is related to an
incarceration arising from the dc it's
so much broader than that
his delusion is this incredible fear
he's frightened that he'll be
his life mary haskins life the
children's life will be snuffed out
that's why he sent the boy to north
carolina he was frightened he got very
upset when he saw that uh
robert
goodman good good
win
was uh searching the internet for
information regarding the children he
took that information and misconstrued
good night
ladies and gentlemen once again i need
to strike that answer
it's an improper answer i struck it
yesterday
i'm striking it again today and
hopefully we won't hear it again
you understand that doctor correct
there's no evidence supporting that
well please disregard it don't consider
it in your deliberations
ask your next question
doctor if you don't understand my
question please just ask me to rephrase
it and i'll do the best that i can i
will specifically and even if you
understand the question just answer his
question to the best of your ability if
mr blinkist needs to follow up with you
he'll follow up we call that redirect
answer the prosecutor's question
so my question is not about the basis
for your opinion
my question was what is the specific
delusion that you have diagnosed for
michael barrison who phil says life has
threatened
by lauren kanarak
and robert goodwin
when did that delusion that specific
delusion start well it started over a
period of time i would say well over a
month
it gradually increased
in intensity but it wasn't just like two
days as well over several weeks
or many weeks
what specific piece of evidence do you
rely on
that the delusion began
well over a month before the shooting
well no one can tell exactly when the
delusion
began
but
based on
his
responding to information he was told he
read and things that occurred it made
him more more frightened
you didn't identify in your report
a specific piece of evidence that shows
that the delusion began well over a
month before the shooting
i didn't do no i didn't not
and you'd agree with me that among the
diagnostic
criteria
for delusional disorder is that the
delusion existed for at least one month
yes i understand that
now you found that the defendant suffers
from a sub-type of delusional disorder
persecutory type yes
what are the symptoms or characteristics
of persecutory type delusional disorder
well
as it says
he feels as if he feels as if there's a
danger out there he feels threatened
personally he feels that
all the things he's doing are being
monitored and he feels as if
that someone
can plan to kill him
and i'm not talking about michael
barrasson in particular i'm talking in
general what are the characteristics of
the cell type of persecutory general
the person
believes
that there's some threat in the outside
environment to him and if it was
analyzed by other people then people
would not come up with that conclusion
so it's a false belief
that the person is in danger
that other people
don't agree with correct
the last part i didn't follow that other
people don't agree with
wasn't the last part of your last answer
that if other people
didn't see it well or other people would
try to talk the person out of it yes
so you'd agree with me that persecutory
type delusional disorder
could be characterized by a person
having a false belief
that there was a danger to themselves
that other people didn't agree with yes
that's broadly speaking about it now you
indicated earlier
that you
received the version of events from
michael barrasso yes
and was that both in combination with
your interviews with him as well as
reviewing the written
statements that he gave to dr simran
you'd agree with me that by the time you
met with him
he had received discovery in this case
yes
and you'd agree with me that by the time
he wrote those statements for dr simran
he had received discovery
how does he know
yeah i'm not sure this witness would
know that well he could say that he
doesn't know that
do you know that doctor no no of course
not
did you ask him that
did i ask him whether he when he
received the discovery did you ask him
or were you aware if he had access to
discovery
when he wrote the written statement no i
don't know something
now you wrote in your report that among
the defendant's fears
were that he told police
that lauren canara had weapons yes
did you listen to any of the 911 calls
in this case
yes
and you're aware that on july 31st
he would ask he was asked
if weapons were involved or mentioned
and his response was no correct judge
let me see a time mark
dr hassan i'm just going to re-ask the
question again because i'm not sure at
what point
i stopped but
you're aware then that on the july 31st
call to 9-1-1 the defendant was asked
were any weapons involved or mentioned
i'm aware it was asked and you're aware
that he responded no correct
you're aware that on august 1st he
called 9-1-1 yes and on that call he was
asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was no
correct
you're aware that on august 3rd he
called 9-1-1 yes and he was asked
whether weapons were involved or
mentioned
yes and his response was i have not
heard a word of that
okay
are you aware on august 5th that he
called 9-1-1 yes
and he was asked if weapons were
involved or mentioned
correct and his response was not so far
correct
you also i think testified yesterday and
it's in your report
that
michael barason told you that he
believed lauren canarac had declared war
on him correct
on the july 31st call to 9-1-1
didn't he indicate this is war and i've
had enough of these people i need them
gone yes i read that
did you ask him what he meant when he
said
that it was war with lauren canara
i took him at his face word
about his view
that um lauren cataract
had um issued some comments earlier that
he had read
using the word war
and then after listening to the 9-1-1
call from july 31st where he said
this is war i've had enough of these
people i need them gone you didn't ask
him what he meant by that no
and you agree with me that on july 31st
when he called 9-1-1 or around the time
he called 9-1-1
he didn't shoot anyone then
no
now i think doctor you talked in your
report uh
and indicated that the defendant was
taken to saint claire's hospital
well i saw on one of the forums that
said st claire's hospital
emergency at the squatter
so that was
that was a mistake in your report no i
was i did i say st class hospital it
said sinclair it was a staff member for
st from sinclair's
well i can direct you to uh page 11 of
your report which is s8
i believe you wrote on the august 7th
entry emergency medical staff at st
clare's hospital reported that on
arrival
correct the way i interpreted was that
these people said since it said on the
form
sinclair's hospital i assume they were
sent from sinclair's hospital
that's why i wrote that
now you also uh you referred to that
report
uh that emt report
yes
i think you testified some yesterday
about uh
when you were asked questions about
various types of amnesia and psychogenic
amnesia dissociative amnesia you were
asked the question
and you responded
with an answer about traumatic brain do
you remember that correct
now you're aware that there's no
diagnosis of traumatic brain injury in
this case
not from the experts there was a rule
out diagnosis of tbi with altered uh
mental status
who gave that one of the doctors i think
the doctor who wrote down the adjustment
disorder had a rule out diagnosis of
tbi
with altered mental state
but you're aware that nobody actually
diagnosed any traumatic brain injury
correct
doctor you never asked michael barrasson
about when he first obtained ruth cox's
gun did you i did
is that in your report i don't know if
it is but i
from my recollection he told me that she
came in very late at night
and
he asked if she had a weapon and he
thought that um the cars could be
subject to
either scrutiny or being
[Music]
open and that he thought that she should
put the weapon in his safe would it
surprise you to know that none of that
is in your report
okay
you didn't think that that was a salient
detail to include in your report
um
i don't think it mattered what time when
or what time you put it in
so you don't think him obtaining the gun
that he's accused of using to shoot two
people
several days later that when he obtained
that you don't think that that matters i
don't think it's
for at least for me i don't feel it's
pertinent to my conclusion in the case
when he received the gun when he put it
in the safe
i have no further questions judge
but
redirect
doctor
yesterday the prosecutor was showing you
numerous articles and different books
with regards to
psychiatry
yes i do
is there an equal number of
articles
and books
that say the exact opposite thing
that he showed you
without a doubt
two hundred percent
as a matter of fact after i left
yesterday
i read the book
that um
mr shellhorn referenced and so the
record is clear you had never been
shown that book or given advanced notice
that he was going to show that to you
correct without a doubt i didn't know
about that book i didn't know about that
reference
did you read that book last night i did
i got it through kindle
and it explains the mystery
and um
what if anything would you like to say
with regards to that in reference to the
specific things that he showed you
well in chapter three
there was uh that's the chapter he
showed me judge not to interrupt but
could we just so the record is clear
i showed dr hassan a number of things
yesterday but just so the record is
clear he can indicate what he's reading
from
which book he's referring to this is the
book by um
um
john um
i want to say bachelor it's not
um
i forgot i forgot it is a butcher
butcher
yes james butcher james butcher
john bachelor a radio uh personality or
was
um the particular item that he that mr
shalhon showed me was a paragraph
describing uh paranoid
features if someone had a high score on
scale six
and i noticed when i looked at it there
was no uh numbers in there and just what
do you mean no numbers what are you no
scores
there's no scores i i i was taken aback
and it was something short what's the
significance of scores well it's low
medium and high
they're completely different there was
none of that in there
so i got the book via kindle last night
and i read that section yeah i
understand why because the author of the
book
said i suggest
you um
look up
articles
by other experts to get more in-depth
information this is what he wrote
chapter three provides a brief can i
just ask what page we're reading from
judge i have the book here so i can
follow along well i i have it from
location 897 in the book so i can tell
you it's somewhere in chapter three
in the area where you showed me that
there were no t scores you had me look
at that with you
continue doctor
chapter three provides a brief overview
of each of the minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory hyphen 2 in
parentheses mmpi type into clinical
content and supplementary skills in turn
more in-depth information on each of
these scales is available in any of the
standard mmpi hyphen 2 reference books
such as butcher richard williams
friedman
malinsky lewin
nichols graham and greene so over here
yes this is a typical reference book
by david nichols who was quite nice to
me one time when i called them up
now if you look in this book here it
gives specific information on scale six
and i referenced it in my uh my report
if you're very high on scale six
paranoia and you're low on schizophrenia
it suggests that the person has a
encrusted delusional disorder
targeted to one particular person
and
a high score on scale six is indicative
or suggestive of a delusional disorder i
gave other references there but that's
what i found yesterday okay now
with regards to his questions concerning
family
is it correct
if i can simplify the term as someone
telling the truth
not telling if you're fainting and not
telling the truth right that's what i
mean whether whether or not someone is
telling you correct correct now
with regards to michael's
repeated statements
to
first aid people
to
the ems
personnel
morristown medical
morristown hospital
and the
morris county correctional facility
where he said he didn't remember
did you take into account
those specific
medical reports and references with
regards to your determination as to
whether or not michael
barrasson was saying well feigning is
determined by testing
it it's not determined by just your your
subtle opinion
if i found no evidence of feigning
either personality or cognitive or
neural psychological with them with the
exception of the tom
that's
questionable results there anyway so to
answer you directly i found no evidence
of feigning
there was repeated uh references that he
couldn't remember
the event
and
in addition to your testing
do those
references
close in time to the incident
um
confirm whether or not
that
testing is accurate
i don't know about that i mean to me um
consistently he reported he couldn't
remember he was days there were
statements that he had partial
consciousness
and
that's
consistent with the possibility of a
mild tbi or
some type of
extreme anxiety that obliterated that
memory
now
with regards to his statement testified
to
where he allegedly said i'm sorry in the
hospital were you aware that prior to
that he was injected with a hundred
milligrams of fentanyl yes and
what if anything would
that drug fentanyl
i don't know that he's qualified to say
that he's not a medical doctor
are you familiar with the effects of uh
fentanyl doctor same objection yeah
if you're going to pursue this i need to
have a 104 hearing outside the presence
of the jury
all right questions with john
yesterday the prosecutor was asking you
questions
as to whether or not someone's
mistaken belief would affect
your delusional diagnosis
did you review the safe sport complaint
um
that lauren canorack made against
michael barrasso yes were there
allegations of judgement
hold on there's an objection mr
bolinkins i didn't finish the question
i know when there's an objection
it doesn't mean you keep talking when
there's an objection
say the same thing to witnesses
sustained
uh prosecutor asks you questions about
the 911
yes with regards to questions that were
repeatedly asked
with regards to those specific instances
did the questions
concerning weapons
have to do with
those this is going to call for
speculation
how does this witness possibly know that
if he heard that
and you're asking him to interpret
the questions
and what was asked by the police officer
and what what the police officer was
asking can't answer that question
you have any follow-up all right you may
step down doctor thank you
so
any further witnesses mr malinkas no
judge other than uh admitting uh
numerous photographs which i don't
believe
right we don't have to do that now we
can do it at a break or at the close of
business we'll get on with the witnesses
so no further witnesses other than the
admission of some photographs and
defense defense arrests
mr
shellhorn does the state have any
rebuttal witnesses
yes
all right call your first rebuttal
witness judge this could can i have uh
dr hassan back in the courtroom yes he
can listen
judge the state will call dr lewis
lesniger all right dr schlesinger
[Music]
my doctor good afternoon
all right left hand on him you know the
routine left hand on the bottom raise
your right hand please listen to my
court card do you stand in the presence
of almighty god that the testimony comes
to this court regarding this matter
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth i do please state
your name must by your last name the
record uh lewis l-o-u-i-s messenger
s-c-h-l-e-s-i-n-g-e-r
thank you oh you may have a seat doctor
please keep your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase
go ahead
prosecutor
thank you good afternoon doctor good
morning
can you please introduce yourself to the
jury and tell them what you do for a
living um well lewis lesninger i'm a
forensic psychologist
what is forensic psychology it's simply
the application of behavioral science to
the law it's as simple as that
are you licensed as a psychologist yes
can you tell the jury about that i'm a
licensed psychologist how long have you
been places since 1976
uh are you board certified yes can you
tell the jury about that
i'm board certified as a forensic
psychologist from the american board of
professional psychology i've been board
certified for well over 30 years
so there is board certification in the
field of psychology definitely
can you tell the jury a little bit about
your educational background
sure i received my doctorate my phd in
1975 from the new school for social
research in new york city
i was a trainee at greystone psychiatric
hospital from 71 to 73
i did my internship with the new jersey
clinical internship program in
psychology from 73 to 74 where i
trained at the new jersey uh state
diagnostic center that was the state's
forensic center at that time
i rotated i did another rotation at
trenton state prison and then trenton
psychiatric hospital the room building
readjustment unit today it's ant klein
forensic center but it used to be called
the varun building
i did some postgraduate training at the
new york center for psychoanalytic
training from 76 to 78 where i took
courses in
psychoanalytic theory and therapy
and i had a postdoctoral individual
supervision from 75 to 77 which is which
is required
i'm licensed board certified
i am a tenured full professor at john
jay college of criminal justice in new
york which is part of the city
university of new york
and um i've been there since uh 1997.
can you can you tell us a little more
about that about your teaching
experience there doctor
john jay college is the is the criminal
justice um school for the city
university of new york city university
mass
university baruch college is the
business school city college is the
arts and john jay's new criminal justice
school
i teach undergraduates master students
and doctoral students
as well i
teach forensic psychology i'm a yeah
full professor of forensic psychology
and i was just going to ask you that
what type of courses do you teach well i
teach um psychopathology um forensic
psychology crime scene analysis
and um homicide teaches a specific
course in home side as well
can you tell the jury a little bit about
some of the professional activities that
you're involved in
well uh professional activities um
well i've had a lot of clinical
experience but other other than my
clinical experience i was um
elected president of the new jersey
psychological association in 1989 prior
to that i was a vice president on the
executive board i was also um a member
and later chair of the state ethics
committee from 1988 from 1982 to 1988 i
was also a member of the forensic
psychology committee from 1980 to the
present
i was president of the new jersey
psychology political action committee
from 91 to 93
i was a member of the board of trustees
of the new jersey psychological
foundation from 96 to 98 i was president
of the society of psychologists in
private practice from 2001 to 2002.
i've been on the executive board of the
essex union county association of
psychologists from 2007 to 2008.
i was elected member of the council of
representatives of the american
psychological association
um i did that from 91 to 94 the american
psychological asses
the council of representatives of the
american psychological association is
really like their executive committee
and um
and so i did that for several years i
was also um treasurer of a division of
group psychotherapy and editor
of that group psychotherapy bulletin
i was an advisory board member from 83
to 88 of the american college of
forensic psychology
i was a member of the board of trustees
of the new jersey academy of psychology
from 1980 to 1987
i was a member and later chair of the
special classification review board at
the adult diagnostic and treatment
center at avenell i was appointed by the
governor of new jersey and the
commissioner of corrections that's the
board that evaluates inmates at the um
adtc sex offender unit and makes
recommendations to the parole board um
for for uh for their release
i have been an associate editor of the
international journal of offender
therapy and comparative criminology from
2005
and on the editorial board of the
journal of threat assessment from 2000
from 1999 to 2003.
doctor can i just interrupt you on that
would you say that you're the editor of
something like that what does that mean
i was the associate editor not the
editor i was an associate what's that
well the editor is in charge of the
journal the editor has an editorial
board and they review papers that are
presented for publication that's
basically what you do they're not a
journal is not limited to
the editorial report very often they'll
send it out to external reviewers as
well
since 2000 i've been a co-principal
investigator on a major research project
with the fbi behavioral analysis unit
down in quantico
where we studied we have thousands of
extraordinary crimes files we got from
the fbi
and we have a major research project
where we study extraordinary crime
sexual murder serial murder serial rape
suicide by cop bias homicide
um domestic homicide and other forms of
serious crime which resulted in some
major publications
as well
in 2004 myself and four of my colleagues
at john jay conducted
the research on uh sexual abuse in a
catholic church
by uh priests and deacons from 1950 to
2002.
the uh u.s con it was under the auspices
of the uf's conference of catholic
bishops the u.s conference of catholic
bishops reached out to john jay to do
this
um for a couple of reasons but
one is
the um
because we had the fbi project
it was going so well let me say one
thing the fbi is a very paranoid
organization they don't not like to
share their information with others so
but they did with us in terms of all
their files you have a room almost the
size of this just filled with files
there was no problem at all in terms of
confidentiality or anything like that so
um the head of the fbi at that time the
the
deputy had a left and was hired by the
u.s conference of catholic bishops to
conduct this study and because of the
very good experience that we had with
the fbi that's how john jay was selected
to do it so we did that and we presented
our results
to to the bishops
i have also been a member of the senate
task force on internet uh information
for registered sex offenders
uh i was i was appointed by the acting
governor and the senate and the senate
president um what happened was um new
jersey needed to uh redo megan's law
that's the community notification
um of registered sex offenders and
before they did that they put together a
task force um i was on it representing
um
mental health um there was someone from
the prosecutor's office the defense bar
uh senator um and verso was on it it was
megan megan cancer's senator uh joe
vitale who was uh um a senator as well
as on it there's someone someone else uh
someone from rutgers was on it as well i
think
and we um basically rewrote the law we
held public hearings and so on um
and there was a number of reasons why
that had to be done but not relevant to
anything
else
i've been uh
on the research advisory board of the
fbi then specifically the national
center for the analysis
of violent crime at the behavioral
analysis unit from 2010 to 2012 and i've
been a periodic instructor at the fbi
since 2008 although i haven't been there
in a while
we're all shut down and so on and i've
had a lot of different jobs
um
over the years clinically i was just
going to ask you if you could tell the
jury about some of your clinical
clinical experience right so um in
addition to being a a tenured professor
i've also had a private practice of
clinical and forensic psychology
since
1976.
i was a consultant at fair oaks hospital
or now at sup called summit hospital
from 76 to 2000
uh where i worked with adults and
adolescents and and almost exclusively
psychological evaluations very limited
therapy
only early on
i've been a consultant at little hill
alina lodge in blairstown new jersey
from 1998 to the president that's a
substance abuse unit a long-term
treatment program for substance abuse
i was also on the staff of the va
medical center in east orange from 1976
to 1999
and there i worked on their alcohol and
substance abuse program i worked on
their uh compensation and pension
program that's where veterans get
evaluated for ptsd
and that type of thing but i also
founded
a violence clinic in the va which the
clint the purpose of the clinic was to
evaluate people with respect to a
problem with violence uh and then we
treated them and it was the first
violence clinic in the entire va system
and it became
brought into the ptsd program when the
ptsd program started
and uh so and i coordinated that from 77
to 92.
prior to that i was on the staff of jfk
medical center in edison i worked
in their mental health center and i also
worked at the rehab unit
as well
and i was a consultant at the edison
police department the juvenile aid
bureau from 75
to 70
75 to 76.
doctor have you ever received any awards
uh in recognition of things you've done
uh yes can you tell the jury about some
of those awards yes um
in 1990 i was
awarded i was awarded psychologist of
the year by the new jersey psychological
association
in 1993 i received the karl f heiser
presidential award from the american
psychological association
in 2003 i received the distinguished
service award from the society of psych
from the society of psychologists and
private practice
from 2005 to present to the president
i've been a distinguished practitioner
in the national academies of practice
the national academies of practice
is based up of nine medical specialists
including psychologists and each
specialty is limited to a hundred people
in that specialty and the purpose is to
advise the united states congress on
matters of health care
and so i i've been on that
and in 2014 i received the distinguished
researcher award from the new jersey
psychological association
i was just going to ask you about some
of your uh professional organizations
that you're a member of yeah uh i'm a
fellow of the american psychological
association a fellow is a little bit
different than being a member um i was a
member for many years but when the
american psychological association
determines that your work your
contribution had national impact they
can elect you to be a fellow it can't be
local or state they have to determine
that it was national impact
so i'm a fellow of the apa
i've been a fellow of
the new jersey psychological association
i said i was president of that um a
while back
i'm also a member of the american
academy of forensic psychology i'm
actually a fellow of the american
academy of forensic psychology it's not
on my cv but i am
a member of the essex union county of
association of psychologists the society
for personality assessment and also a
member of the uh international rorschach
exchange
and um
what's that
it's just a scientific group that sends
out
once or twice a year uh a
book called russia canna and it's this
research and and
people write things about their their uh
research on the rorschach
have you ever published anything related
to the field of psychology yes can you
uh tell the jury have you ever published
any books i've had 12 books published
in
1978 i published violence perspectives
on murder and aggression
in 1980 i published handbook on stress
and anxiety
in 1981
psychopathology of homicide
in
1983
the title of the book was sexual
dynamics of anti-social behavior and
there was a second edition in 1997.
in 1989 i published sex murder and sex
aggression
in 1996 i published
explorations in criminal psychopathology
clinical syndromes with forensic
implications and there was a second
edition of 2007. the the reason i
published that was clinical syndromes
with forensic implications because the
dsm often doesn't do
well with a lot of disorders that are
forensically related because the dsm
weekly wasn't set up to be a forensic
manual it's set up for hospital practice
mental health centers offices and so on
so um so that book
supplemented it in in a sense so what
you mean is there is there nuance to
applying diagnoses from the dsm in a
forensic setting
well not nuanced there's disorders
that are um
that you see are we still doing
qualifications at this point
uh i think we are are we mr show who we
are all right save that question for
later
so moving on you were telling us about
some of your books yeah and then 2000 i
published serial offenders current
thought recent findings
um in 2004 sexual murder cataphract and
compulsive homicides a specific type of
sexual murder and the second edition
came out last year in 2017
i uh published a book titled psychiatric
aspects of criminal behaviors the
collected papers of eugene ravage this
is an edited book eugene revitch was a
psychiatrist and a teacher of mine
and um
he actually became a mentor of mine and
we became colleagues and friends
and
his
papers many of which were published in
the 1950s and 60s and 70s are as
relevant today
as they were then and they meant so much
to me when i trained i almost memorized
them and i didn't want them to get lost
in the archives somewhere so i put it
together into an edited book where the
first part is on uh sexual aggression
the second part on criminal behavior and
the third part of the book is on
epilepsy and epileptoid violence dr
revich is also a neurologist
and there's a number of articles in
there on what's called paroxysmal
manifestations of non-epileptic origin
sounds fancy but all it means is an
explosion that's really not a result of
epilepsy sometimes that's hard to
differentiate so um
so that's that book it was a book of
honor really to somebody and got really
really good reviews um
i i which i was happy about
but i had nothing to do with the content
i just put it together
doctor have you ever written any uh
chapters in any books yes i've written i
think about 25 uh chapters in um
in different people's books i've been
invited to write chapters and um
about so i think it's around 25 chapters
in different books some are my own books
some were many were other people's books
as well have you ever published articles
in any journals
yes i've published
about i believe it's 43 articles in
peer-reviewed scientific journals
um what's uh what's a peer-reviewed
scientific journal a peer-reviewed
scientific journal is when you publish
an article researcher it doesn't have to
necessarily be research it could be a
theoretical article or a literature
review
you send it into a journal and then you
get what's called a blind review your
identity is removed
all identifiers are removed and they
send it out to three four five experts
in the field to review it your peers and
then they give feedback and then you
do what you have to do um and so that's
what that's what the peer review process
is it's an um it's a fairly long process
and
in many top journals there's about a 90
rejection rate so a lot of people don't
realize that but i've published in all
of the top uh journals
including the american academy
the journal of the american academy of
forensic psychiatry
behavioral science in the law
journal of forensic sciences
journal of family violence uh
international journal defender therapy
and comparative criminology
um
and other and other in other top
journals and a lot of it is on
various it's almost all on criminal
behavior and extraordinary criminal
behavior sexual murder
serial sexual murder necrophilia crime
scene staging undoing which is symbolic
reverse letter homicide crime scene
foreign object
insertions uh and so on we recently
published and a lot of this was in
collaboration with the fbi because we
have their um extraordinary cases from
all over the country
um and recently i we published an
article on confessions um you know you
hear a lot about false confession
there's a lot of research on false
confession but our study was not on
false confession was on confessions how
do people confess because people confess
in different ways depending upon
their crime
doctor have you ever testified at a
trial
yes
what uh can you estimate approximately
how many times you've testified at trial
uh i never kept a record of how many
times i've done this and i'm not good at
estimating how many times i've done
things but i've been doing this now 46
years 100 200 perhaps 300 times i i just
don't know
and were you qualified as an expert yes
what are some of the topics that you've
testified regarding i mean i've
testified in state of mind cases
insanity diminished capacity passion
provocation duress voluntary
intoxication competency to proceed
competency wave miranda rights
sentencing issues
um
have you ever been hired
obviously you're here testifying as my
witness said on behalf of the prosecutor
today have you ever been hired by the
defense i have in the in the first third
of my career i've testified just about
exclusively for the defense i was hired
mostly by the defense in the last third
of my career i've been retained mostly
by the prosecutor and in the middle it
kind of went in different ways
have you ever given an opinion that was
different from the party or the side
that hired you yes
can you estimate in the last
call it 10 years approximately how many
times that's happened well i can tell
you the ex the exact time
in the past 10 or a little bit longer 10
maybe almost 15 years because i have a
record of it and the reason i have a
record of it is
someone asked me just that question
maybe 10 12 years ago
and and they asked me essentially did
you ever get hired by the prosecutor for
example and gave an opinion a consistent
with a defense expert and i said yes now
when you're in court and someone asks
you if you ever did something and you
say yes the next question is how many
times did you do it and i didn't know
how many times i did it so i kept the
record then
of the times of the various um offices
that i was retained by uh as well as
defense as well as defense and so what
is the number in the approximately last
10 to 15 years that you've given an
opinion different from the party that
hired you okay now you want a number so
i'm going to have to count this so
just give me a second okay okay just
give me a second
okay i i came up with 30.
30 right yeah 30. since you started
keeping track yeah
doctor do you have any experience with
psychological testing
um
yes i have um
i have extensive experience with
psychological testing
psychological testing is very simple
it's a beta it's simply a way to measure
mental process it's it's it's it's
really nothing more difficult and more
complicated than that
and this generally pretty
straightforward psychological testing
but i will say if you don't know what
you're doing you can really mess this up
real quickly
i'm sorry no i was going to say i taught
psychological testing for over 20 years
when i was on the faculty of um the new
jersey medical school i sent a faculty
over there i don't know if i even
mentioned that but i was in a faculty
over there at um umd and j for um from
90. from 77 to
99 i think in 2000. for 23 years i
taught psychological testing to third
year medical students who rotated
through psychiatry service
i also conducted a year-long
psychodiagnostic seminar for our
doctoral interns who are training over
at the va
and um did that for over 20 years um
as well
um
in addition i've published two papers on
the rorschach
um in journals
i um also developed my own projective
test
um entitled the uh the criminal fantasy
test and it was really based on as a
projective test and based on the format
of the thematic app reception test which
is simply a test you show a person a
somewhat ambiguous picture and their job
is to create a story based on the
picture and you get kind of their inner
fantasies their inner thoughts and so on
because sometimes an individual patient
or otherwise if you ask them a question
they won't tell you directly but if you
give them a test and ask them to create
a story very often it's revealed in that
so i i was always impressed with the
content that i got from the tad so i
worked with an artist a colleague of
mine worked with an artist and we
developed
a criminal fantasy test of 12 different
ambiguous sorts of crimes and the object
was to create a story about it it was
published in 1981 in the journal of
clinical psychology at that time a
number of test publishers wanted me to
develop this into a a market a
marketable test where you could you know
sell it and that sort of thing and i did
not do it i should have done it it's one
of my greatest professional regrets
because i think of all of the people
that i saw over the past 40 years
but i i didn't do it but anyway um
i did that
also um
i discussed psychological testing in uh
several of my books or many of my books
and and how to do it what to do what not
to do and how to go about it and so on
would you ever render a diagnosis based
on a psychological test no you never
render a diagnosis based on a
psychological test psychological testing
can support a diagnosis a diagnosis is
made clinically and it's made based on
the clinical criteria symptoms and
behaviors delineated in the dsm-5 now
the dsm-5 this is a diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders
it's been around since 1952 it goes
through different editions that's how
you make a diagnosis based on symptoms
and behavior now what's the value of
testing well testing can support a
diagnosis or it can go in a different
direction and not support a diagnosis
but you never make a diagnosis based on
psychological testing as a matter of
fact if you look at some of the tests
that have computer printouts i don't use
those but
a lot of people do it says very clearly
these are hypotheses these are
suggestions these are for your
consideration but no the answer your
question directly you never make a
diagnosis based on psychological testing
judge at this point i'd like to offer dr
schlesinger as an expert in the field of
forensic psychology
mr blankis do you have any questions as
to the qualifications of the doctor or
any opposition
all right
based on the background of dr
schlesinger
as outlined in his testimony i do find
pursuant to rule 702 of the new jersey
rules of evidence that he qualifies as
an expert
and he may uh in forensic psychology and
may testify in the form of opinion
i make this determination based on
his
education his knowledge skill
experience
and training uh and extensive work
history
all right very good he'll qualify as an
expert go ahead mr michelle horn
doctor is there any difference between a
psychologist and a psychiatrist in a
forensic setting uh yes yes there is
there is a difference
there's a difference in training a
psychiatrist after college goes to
medical school and studies medicine
and then he or she does a four-year
residency in psychiatry where they study
you know diagnosis dsm and usually
treatment with medication not all the
time but usually treatment with
medication and some
psychotherapy
a psychologist after uh college goes to
graduate school for four five six years
depending upon
their program and their how they get
through it
and gets training in behavioral science
and psychopathology diagnosis evaluation
uh
and uh testing and treatment and so on
and then a psychologist does um a
clinical internship a pre-doctoral
internship and then he does
at least a year of post-doctoral
supervision or more
psychologists and psychiatrists trained
together i mean i've been trained by
psychiatrist dr revich was a mentor of
mine and he was my
he's a psychiatrist he was my main
teacher
and um
uh and and so i've been trained by
psychiatrists but i taught at the
medical school for years um i taught
undergraduates that's medical students
they're called undergraduates
in medicine um
for years um i taught um interviewing
with with them the testing i said with
the third year residents and i was with
third-year medical students and with a
psychiatry residents i supervise them
with
their their experience at the substance
abuse unit and specifically with group
therapy and evaluation with respect for
substance abuse in addition
psychologists and psychiatrists practice
together all the time i practiced for 25
years with a psychiatrist in summit
sergio estrada um you know we each had
our patients he did medication i did
psychotherapy i did evaluations for him
it's a great collaboration so uh and you
know i i've worked with them and
throughout
and very very very collegially that's
the difference basically
doctor in this case were you asked to
see and examine michael barrasso uh yes
do you see mr barryson in court
um i think it's this i think that's
michael sitting next to his attorney
although i will say looks very different
than when i saw him can you describe uh
what's different about it when i saw him
he was well groomed it looked
appropriate and now he looks along with
disheveled hair that's not how he looked
when i saw him do you recall
approximately when you saw him
um i saw him
uh
exactly on january 29th march 12th and
april 29th 2021 last year
and doctor are you referring to a copy
of your report yes
judge i'm just going to indicate for the
record that that was marked as s 404
for purposes of the record all right
very good
doctor when you were first asked uh to
see and examine michael barissone what
did you do first
well first i did psychological but
before i saw him i familiarized myself
with the discovery and and that's what
that's what you have to do for a
forensic assessment
has three parts
the facts of the case that you get from
the discovery the discovery is the
police reports and witness statements
and all the rest
the second part of a forensic assessment
is the psychopathology is there a
disorder what's the disorder and so on
and the third part is that the jury will
take the facts and the disorder second
thought and relate it to a legal
standard whatever that is
now in this case uh you indicated that
you did review discovery and that that's
an important part of the process
do you recall what discovery you
reviewed i reviewed the complete states
case everything there was thousands and
thousands of pages of text messages and
everything and there were um
uh um
videos you know recorded statements
i was just going to ask you did you
watch or listen to any of the recorded
witness statements yes some were videos
statements some are just uh audio but i
i listen to everyone yes why would you
listen to the statements or watch the
statements as opposed to relying on a
summary or a report
well you can read the summary of the
report too a lot of the statements are
summarized in the police report but
that's not the way to do it you want to
see exact that's some person saying what
they've found to be significant and you
you are obligated to look at it yourself
and make your own determination and get
a you know get a look of what the person
said in whole not just a summary of what
the person said
did you also review any uh
reports that were authored by uh any
psychiatrist hired by the defendant yes
and that was that dr simmering dr simran
do you know dr simran i know dr
simmering very well i've known dr simran
for over 30 years i have the highest
regard for dr simmering he's a friend of
mine dr simmering is competent he's
experienced he's intelligent he's funny
and he's and he's extremely nice guy
which i think i said to you at least 50
times
and i've worked with stock dr simmering
on cases i've worked opposite dr
simmering on cases i referred cases to
dr simran he's referred cases to me i
have the highest regard for dr simmering
but i disagree with him in this case but
it has nothing to do with my high regard
for dr simran have you agreed with him
in certain cases yes and have you
disagreed with them in certain cases yes
do you know how much time you spent with
michael barrasson in this case uh yes i
spent
13.25 hours 13 and a quarter hours and i
think i meant to ask you and i'm not
sure if i did were you aware of dr
simran's diagnosis in this case yes and
that's why you said you disagree with
them in this case correct
now you indicated that you met with
michael barrasson that he looked
different when you met him yeah what was
his demeanor when you met with him
well when i first met with him he was
very very tearful i mean he was crying
uncontrollably he almost at times was
hard to console him um he was very upset
about the whole thing and if i could
just refer to my report
um yeah he was tearful emotional crying
he became animated at times particularly
when discussing uh lauren
and
robert goodwin and the whole
circumstances uh with respect to that he
would stand up get animated and so on he
was very emotional um about it
and um
yeah he did that um but he he you know
he after i caught he calmed down and he
participated fine he was cooperative
completely answered my questions
except for some resistance towards the
end
now how would you describe his ability
to recount uh certain things that
happened
michael's
memory from as to what happened was
excellent
he's i spent hours with him i think he's
over six hours maybe talking about what
had happened he gave me a day by day
account of the activities that happened
sometimes it was an hour by our account
now occasionally he would say well july
24th we uh you know i woke up and i did
this oh by the way there's some
something happened on july 23rd and then
he would go back to that but that's
normal that's how that's how people
remember things and recall things but he
remembered in great detail
everything i was very impressed by his
um memory
how would you describe his concentration
during the times that you met with him
when i was with him his concentration
was basically okay i was with him for
hours and hours at a time now he was
emotional he was crying and so on but he
was okay his concentration was basically
okay what would you say was the most
outstanding clinical feature that you
observed
i was just crying and and is being so
upset about the uh about the whole thing
he's extremely emotional and um and
animated that was the most outstanding
uh feature
other than that um no he was pleasant he
was a pleasant to deal with pleasant to
talk to he was
very appropriate
and um
nothing bizarre or unusual in his
demeanor other than what i just said or
what he said
now you describe
in general
what a forensic evaluation or
examination entails
how do you look at criminal behavior
criminal behavior is best understood in
three stages
the pre-crime context criminal paper
doesn't come out of nowhere there's
there's a context to understand it then
there's the actual offense itself and
then there's the post-crime behavior and
that's really the best way to understand
uh from my perspective from a
psychological perspective criminal
behavior and how do you
learn that well you learn that from the
discovery you don't learn that from what
the defendant tells you you learned that
from the discovery i should say
one i should correct myself
a very nuanced thing i just want to say
a little bit different
yes he told me what happened on a
day-by-day hour by hour sometime basis
but i i want to emphasize that's his
perception of what happened i'm not i
don't know if everything he told me is
exactly correct
um but that's what his perception was of
it
but yeah
yes
and i think you you described earlier
doctor you started to talk about the way
memory works
and can you explain a little bit more
about that in light of your last answer
well memory is not there's no video
camera inside here that makes a video
tape of what goes on memory is a
constructive process we construct our
memory if somebody asks you what did you
have for breakfast yesterday you'll
probably give them an answer but it's
constructed it's not that you
necessarily have an exact memory of it
it's so you know yeah everybody will
find what you think and then you'll and
the infrastructure that's the way human
memory uh works and you have you know
you can have an event i mean you see
this in in legal practice all the time
not necessarily criminals say an
accident three people look at an
accident and three people give
statements are those three statements
going to be exact no they're not going
to be exact that's how they perceive it
people perceive things differently based
on many factors
and if people perceive things
differently
does that mean that one or more of them
is having a delusion absolutely
not doctor you indicated that you uh
as part of your examination uh gave the
defendant some psychological tests yes
and i think you outlined those beginning
on page 50 in your report
okay just give me a second please
yes but before we get there can i ask
you
how do you choose what tests you're
going to use in a forensic examination
yeah i give
it psychological testing to ever i won't
say every single person but i would say
99.99
of the people i give a standard battery
of psychological testing too
i give the rorschach the thematic app
reception test the bender gestalt
projective figure drawings the mmpi 2
and a version of the wechsler scales
that's an intelligence test
if the case requires i'll add additional
tests
um
tests for malingering mental disorders
for example tests from lingering memory
memory for example and other types of
tests as well but i give that standard
battery to everybody why i just want to
get a measure i want to get a baseline
measure of the individual and when i
start my evaluation in the forensic case
i start with psychological testing i
don't start with what did you do and
what happened no i start with that
because it's a sort of a breaks the ice
you know and then some simple tests and
it's a rapport builder and this type of
thing so that's what i do
now in this case did you give the
defendant any tests related to
intellectual uh examination yes what did
you give him i gave the
wechsler-abbreviated scale of
intelligence the wechsler-abbreviated
scale of intelligence is an abbreviated
intelligence test that has a 0.93
correlation with the complete wechsler
adult intelligence scale revised means
you're tapping essentially the same
thing now why did i give him the
abbreviated test rather than the full
wexler intelligence scale very simple
intelligence is not an issue in the case
meaning intelligence is not an issue
before the court
if intelligence was an issue before the
court for example
the issue is competency to stand trial
based on limited intelligence
not necessarily intellectual disability
borderline intelligence so on then
you're obliged to give the full test if
it was competency to waive your miranda
rights based on intelligence if it's a
social security disability evaluation
for example and intelligence is an issue
then uh yes but there but in this
particular case michael is an entirely
intelligent individual
he ran a very complicated business he
had um with lots of moving parts um he
had a location in new jersey at a
location in florida there was a lot of
people that were employees there were
students and trainees there there were
animals there horses there's all kinds
of consultants coming in horseshoe
people and veterinarians and whatnot um
he said these monthly expenses like 36
000 a month that's a lot of money that's
a very big and complicated business he's
highly intelligent intelligence is not
an issue in this case prior to seeing
him i also read dr simran's report who
described them as highly intelligence uh
and i gave some weight to that as well
so there's no need in my judgment to do
anything beyond what i did
now after giving him that test did that
uh
corroborate what your impression was
going in yes let me uh refer to my
report on page 50. i found his um
full-scale iq which is intelligence
question 119 that's the highest end of
average just one point below superior
his verbal comprehension index is 120
that's superior and his perceptual
reasoning index is 112. this is all
above average intelligence there's
nothing wrong with michael's
intelligence nothing he's an intelligent
individual
did you give him any tests related to
personality functioning uh yes
can you and
i know you had already said you give a
standard battery a test
what in general are the the uh to be
personality functioning tests looking
for we're looking at well you're
generally looking at personality from
different perspectives from different
ways i gave him the rorschach
i gave him the thematic apperception
test the mmpi 2
and projective figure drawings and
there's a combination here of projective
tests and combination and the mmpi which
is a more objective let's say
quantitative test um as well and i know
you said you give some of these tests to
establish a baseline but what
specifically do you hope to learn by
giving these tests that would have value
to your entire examination sure well the
rorschach for example has been around
since the 1920s this is an excellent
test if used properly
it's a very good test to determine
reality contact
reality testing for example you show a
card and some of these cards look like
bat and butterflies and that's everybody
i think knows that from the media and
whatnot so a person says who looks like
a bat a butterfly or some sort of wing
creature that's pretty good reality
testing what if a person says to it
looks like an enemy
well that's not that's not typical and
that gives you some insight into that
it's very good to determine if there's a
thinking disorder a formal thought
disorder does the person say for example
it looks like a bat because here's the
wings here's the body here's the antenna
here's the feet that's very logical
thinking what if a person says to you it
looks like a bat because of that white
dot right in the middle
what bats have white dots that's showing
a disorder of thought they're drawing a
giant conclusion based on a tiny bit of
information that's a red sign
what if a person says it looks like a
bat
response one it looks like two
alligators over here on the end response
two
that's fine what if a person says it
looks like a bat with alligators
attached to its wings
now that's a thinking disorder that's a
problem with thinking you're putting
parts of reality together that should be
kept separate
um and so some of those are some of the
things you get from the rorschach um
also
the rorschach is also very good to give
you personality structure how strong or
weak is the underlying personality
structure for example when you go to buy
a house you hire a structural engineer
not just to look at what the painting is
outside but to you know go take those
tiles you know off with a flashlight to
see what the structure is to see how
strong the house is the rorschach is a
very good test to determine whether the
structure is the level of a personality
disorder um more severe structural
disorganization schizophrenia or
something like that
so it's a it's a very good test to fuse
properly
now before i ask you about the rorschach
in this specific uh case
i wanted to ask you a little bit about
the war shot itself are there more than
one
testing uh or uh scoring system yes
there's there's um
there's been a number of scoring systems
used over the years
rorschach himself it's rorschach because
that's his name herman rorschach he had
his own system another guy named samuel
beck had a system uh bruno klopfer had a
system
um
zigman pietrowski had a system there's a
whole bunch of these systems i trained
on the bec system but i switched to
klopfer because it's much better
clinically i think it's actually the
best
what happened in the uh mid 1970s to um
to the 1980s a guy named john ecksner
came around
and created
his own system he called it the
comprehensive system why he said well
all these systems are good i'm going to
put it all together and i'm going to
make it in a very quantitative fashion
which sounded good and everybody was
interested in that
now i had training on the exeter system
from john exner
how because back in i can't remember was
79 80 or 81 when i was the va john extra
came there he was promoting his system
all around the country and he's a good
marketer he really really is good and he
gave a series of lectures maybe i don't
think it was more than five five
two-hour lectures to go over his system
um
but i never liked it now now why didn't
i like it not because i'm so smart
because i'm not but what he was doing is
he was making the rorschach which is the
projective test something that it's not
it was never really intended to be that
but okay he wanted to do it in a
quantitative way
the system really became very very
popular throughout the world
particularly in the 1980s
and the 1990s and and schools were
teaching this
and workshops are given all over the
world and computer printouts and books
and all the rest of it
the problem began in the mid-1990s
where
it was determined that there was a lot
of problems with the test in terms of
its validity
now i should say this also
exner put together what he called
the exner
research council that members of the
research council are were top
still are they're all alive a top-notch
people who did research and promoted
this and did workshops and so on greg
meyer is one joni maher is another one
don viglione is another one phil erdberg
is the fourth there's one other person i
can't remember
and when and these are top-notch people
and when they started hearing this that
there's problems with the system
they thought initially maybe this is one
off
and then more more problems came
and then um
by around 2000
it just became untenable and uh john
exner died i think was 2006 about 15
years ago and i i asked i mean one of
the people on on um
the excellent research council is a good
friend of mine phil lertberg so i asked
him did you wait the excellent to die
before you before you completely they
laughed i never got an answer but i
think i know the answer anyway um
they decided they did research on their
own and they said this can't go on
and they published um a meta-analysis
m-e-t-a a meta-analysis is an analysis
of analyses
and they published it in a prestigious
journal called psychological bulletin
and a couple of other journals as well
that really talked about the problems in
the journal that it's just and the
problems were too there's problems with
the normative data and the validity data
the normative data means how the test
was normed by exner he didn't do he
didn't collect information and send it
out for the peer review process he
didn't do that he collected information
and put it in his book and said these
are the norms well that's a problem
and the validity
data as well
now i gave you a number of articles on
that now i didn't follow all of the
details of the problems with the extra
system because i don't use it
i knew that there was a problem with it
because phil herberg's a friend of mine
we discussed it and
and so on and
and and to be very direct a lot of
people that promoted this were quite
embarrassed
when this started happening because
don't forget they're spending years of
their professional career teaching this
promoting it and so on and so what the
exeter research council did after they
published a series of articles
concluding
that it's not a valid
system of scoring and you shouldn't use
it now i want to make something clear
this is not my opinion this is not an
opinion this is a conclusion reached by
the exner research council those
individuals closely connected with exner
and the and the system
they decided to put together and they
were committed to a quantitative
approach to rorschach they put together
a new system they tried to redo it they
thought first maybe we could redo it cut
this they said it was just not
salvageable and so they put together a
new system called the rorschach
performance assessment system and i
think i gave you a manual um and all the
people listed there are all the people
on the exner rorschach council um do you
have another question
yes all right we're getting a little too
narrative here
yeah so i had asked them about the the
different story systems and about the
extra system we heard a lot about that
yesterday no i i understand
just
ask another question follow up if you
need to doctor at some point were you uh
made aware that another doctor named dr
charles uh hassan had examined the
defendant in this case uh yes and were
you provided with a copy of his report
yes
are you aware whether or not he uh
administered the rorschach test to
michael barrison oh yes he did
no he did okay well what just give me a
second
what's a little bit distracted until
yeah
um
no he did not administer uh the
rorschach to him he used my rorschach
findings and said he rescored it using
the exner system and he submitted it to
the exnor um computer program which is
still there i should say yeah you can
still get this obviously it's run now by
exner's daughter she's not a
psychologist and she works with a
psychologist in france europe and frank
i think it's france and um and japan and
so you can still get this so yes i'm
aware of that he administered to him he
rescored it using the exner system
now you said that you used the clopper
system correct um what were your results
after uh scoring michael barissone's
rorschach with the clock for test
well again it's not just the see that's
another problem that's not just the
scoring system i you know i heard so
much
you know about scoring systems that you
know the rorschach is not just read it
to a scoring system it's how i explained
it before so my findings from the
rorschach i found that there was inner
anxiety conflict and tension problems
relaxing
um
there were a number of what's called
achromatic perceptions there was
attention to the um it looks like uh a
bat because it's black using the the the
black color which is a marker for um
depression or depressive vulnerability
um
so he has symptoms depression anxiety
he's not withdrawn from the outside
world
his inner life is dominated somewhat by
impulsive tendencies and there's some
form of acting out
likely there
his responses that he gave were well
connected to the stimulus material his
reality testing was completely intact
there's no evidence of a thought a
formal thought disorder his thinking was
clear and logical there's nothing
suggestive of schizophrenia psychosis or
even borderline traits he gave two
slightly regressive perceptions and
that's um
throwing paint fireworks that type of
thing and it's very very consistent with
you finding individuals who have a
personality disorder and uh
those were the responses in my report i
concluded exactly on page 52 what his
responses were they're logical
well-formed well connected to the
stimulus material upon which they were
based meaning the reality testing
is good
and
no structural disorganization
i also found there's a capacity for
empathy he had an adequate number of
human perceptions which means he has an
ability to establish good interpersonal
relationships
with people
um
did you render any diagnoses based on
the results of the rorschach examination
no you never render a diagnosis on the
basis of any test a test
can give you just what i said all of
these different indices and that could
support or not support a diagnosis but a
diagnosis again is never based on
psychological testing
doctor moving on to the mnpi
uh
what what if you could explain that test
in a general sense
it's 310.
i don't know if anyone else needs a
break
i do
if you get my meaning
so um we're just gonna it's gonna be
short because i know we're just sitting
in the afternoon so just 10 quick
minutes
relax for 10 minutes use the facilities
if you have to do that and we'll come
back at 20 after and pick that all right
very good
[Music]
[Music]
you can step down doctor
you can just step
watching
[Music]
are you bringing the witness in officer
thank you my preceded ladies and
gentlemen will proceed
with the direct examination
go ahead mr shelton thank your honor
doctor just to finish up on the point
of the
i'm sorry
okay
i heard my own voice there judge and i
i think it's okay
are we good miss radler all right very
good please proceed mr shelton doctor
just one final question on the rorschach
you indicated that you had uh reviewed
dr hassan's
uh
rescoring with the egzner what was your
impression of that restore
the the um
again the the test is the the
it's invalid without a doubt but
um
there's some interesting points here
that seem to have been left out for
example if you look at page
12 of 13
number 21
says here
this is from the i'm reading it now this
person meaning michael appears to be
excessively committed to seeing the
world accurately he is consequently
capable of perceiving people and events
realistically but he is also likely to
be the highly precise impressions he
forms of situations
only rarely we allow himself the risk of
forming an oppression that may be
inexact and then it goes down
to number 24 which i thought was
important generally speaking he displays
an adaptive capacity to think logically
and coherently
he is capable as most people have come
to reasonable conclusions about
relationships between events and
maintaining a connected flow of
associations which ideas follow each
other in a comprehensible manner i think
that's important because that's the
opposite of a psychosis his thinking is
clear and logical based on this i don't
know why that was left out
and then it goes on the next page third
page 13 of 13.
going down the third paragraph would
start situation related stress because
he's consequently more vulnerable than
most people becoming acutely upset
anxious even disorganized and his
situationally determined stress overload
is also likely to appear as capacity for
self-control and create a potential for
impulsiveness in what he thinks and says
or does and then two paragraphs down he
displays an adaptive capacity to think
logically and coherently
and the last sentence is there's a
connected flow of associations in which
ideas
follow each other in a comprehensive
manner
this is all the opposite of a psychosis
why isn't that in a report why wouldn't
you
put that in come on
so i thought that was um noteworthy and
that's why i'm bringing it up and doctor
is that the riap
no that's the the rorschach
interpretation assistance program see
exner what he got from the expert judge
just so the record's clear that's marcus
s435 i was going to ask you that
question s 435 okay
after moving on to the mmpi
could you generally explain what that
test is and what you're looking for sure
the mmpi it's the minnesota multi-phasic
personality inventory test has been
around since the 1940s from the
university of minnesota that's why it's
called minnesota
personality inventory multiphasic just
means many different parts
the test has been around for years
and it has been re-standardized in the
early 90s by
a guy named james butcher and james
butcher is from the university of
minnesota so he's very knowledgeable on
this test he's really the person who did
the re-standardization
i've used the mmpi for years and what i
use is
i use the 10 basic clinical scales 1
through 10 and 10 validity scales now
here's how the test is set up
before you interpret the profile the
test tells you how the subject was
taking the test
were they being
overly defensive
and and denying problems that everybody
has such as never had a headache never
had a bad day true well that will
elevate that validity profile
are they over endorsing items to make
them appear more disturbed than they
actually are they have every symptom
bugs crawling up my skin i hear voices
martians control my brain things like
that an over endorsement
of items or are they trying to
respond to items in a socially
appropriate fashion
um showing high moral values
and what's socially expected for example
before i vote in an election i
thoroughly investigate the candidate's
position on all of the issues true well
very few people do that but it's
socially appropriate so before you
interpret the 10 clinical scales you
look to see how the person was going
about taking the test and then you look
at the 10 clinical scales
very important
lecture number one
in the mmpi if you're teaching this
is the labels
of the 10 clinical scales should never
be taken literally it was never meant to
be that so for example if
if a person has a high elevation on
scale 4 the label is psychopathic
deviate that does not mean the person is
a psychopath it doesn't mean that
scale 8 is labeled schizophrenia if a
person has a high elevation on scale 8
it doesn't mean the person is
schizophrenic it never meant that
scale 6 for example is labeled paranoia
if you have a high elevation on scale 6
that does not mean the person is
paranoid as a matter of fact most not
all but most flagrantly paranoid
individuals don't score high on that at
all
and if you look at butcher's
book i showed the prosecutor i don't
know if that any of that came out but
anyway he has a section that says
the literal interpretation do not
literally interpret these scale names
and the first sentence is if you do
you're poorly trained that's not me
that's butcher saying that so if you
think a high elevation on scale six
means you're paranoid it means one thing
according to butcher you're poorly
trained you don't understand what's
going on and if you read the description
from butcher on
on an elevation on scale six
it's nothing about delusions and and all
the rest of it so when i hear for
example in dr um hassan's report and i
i'm i do not want to be disrespectful at
all i'm trying my best not to be and i
don't want to be
but i but he said something to the
effect i don't know anybody that would
look at this high scale six and
interpret it anything different than
paranoid psychosis really i don't know
anybody that would including butcher who
wrote the book on it so it's just
incorrect
now
when you gave this test to michael
barissone what were the results that you
came up with well i gave the test
the validity on page 53 if anybody's
following this the validity scales show
a non-significant exaggeration of
symptoms so that's not a problem there
was a slight attempt to give socially
approved answers
concerning self-control moral values but
it didn't invalidate the test sometimes
the validity skills are high and it
invalidates it that is not the case here
i found mild depression anxiety
suicide threats and attempts are
possible inner anger irritability
suspiciousness these are common symptoms
and individuals likely control their
anger but sometimes they episodically
explode and surprise those around them
now how am i getting that it's not just
scale six but he had another scale
elevation without getting into the weeds
high scale four low scale five that's
sometimes called a masculine protest
meaning individuals feel insecure and
try to
compensate for that by by demonstrating
that they're dominant in some way
also with the mmpi
what you do not do
or let me put it by the way what you do
do is you have to look at what's called
critical items
critical items are
what items is he responding to that's
elevating the scale but this is common
sense and it really have to do it now
i'm looking at this is dr hassan's
findings and if you look at critical
items
let me show you these are the items that
elevated the scale that that michael
responded to also i should say this
before i even get into this it is not at
all uncommon for criminal defendants
pending a serious trial to have a high
elevation on scale six because a lot of
it is reality based people are
persecuting them and and out to get them
and talking about them so here's the
items that michael responded to doctor
just before you judge this i believe has
been marked as s434 for identification
all right and what is that exactly those
are scale scores no this is judge this
is the mmpi two um extended score report
okay yeah
and this is your understanding that dr
assan had rescored
your scores or or used your scores and
re-scored it
on his own oh yes but that's not the
point i'm making now i just wanted to
make the record clear yeah okay right
right right
go ahead
okay um so if you look at the critical
items now i did this and he did it too
how do i know it's right here
i am sure i get a raw deal from life
true
someone has it in for me true i believe
i'm being plotted against true i believe
i'm being followed true i feel i've
often be punished without cause true it
is safer to trust nobody true given
michael's situation now and the
circumstances you're in this is all
reality-based this is not a delusion or
a psychosis this is the what he's
experiencing right now there's a there's
a couple of other ones
someone has it in for me true i believe
i'm being plotted against true i believe
i'm being followed true i believe i'm
being talked about true
i have no enemies who really wish to
harm me false people say insulting and
vulgar things about me true every one of
these
is
based and so when you get um
an mmpi you have to use your common
sense you don't throw your common sense
out and and
and and not look at what he responded to
that's what you have to do when you do
it you see all of those are reality
based there is no basis at all to
conclude that the results of the mmpi
shows paranoid psychosis it does not it
absolutely does not
doctor you didn't uh render a diagnosis
based on your administering the mmpi or
the results you got from that test of
course not you never
no diagnosis from psychological tests
none
before i ask you about the two other two
tests that you gave doctor uh did you
also review dr hassan's uh or hassan's
excuse me uh results on the pai
yes
now
the the pai it's called the personality
assessment inventory this is a good test
now i mentioned the exeter bad test bad
scoring system rorschach good test but
system is bad
the mcmi the belong clinical multi-axle
inventory he also gave which is a
terrible test shouldn't use but this is
a good test the personality assessment
inventory i don't know of any research
article that said otherwise
it's like the mmpi basically
a little shorter
and um
it it's very good now when you look at
this test i think it's 17 pages long i'm
not 100 sure judge for the record uh the
doctor's referring to what's been marked
as s
thank you
all right thank you now you look at this
and and again
this on the cover sheet here says what
all of these say and i'm not just to
read the beginning of it says interpret
information contained in this report
should be viewed only as one source of
hypotheses about the individual being
evaluated do you see that same in all of
these tests these are hypotheses
suggestions you don't make a diagnosis
based on a test but anyway when you look
at this test i open up the first page
and what do i see on the top
in bold capital letters warning
validity scales indicate hypotheses may
not be valid it doesn't say
consider this take a look at this by the
way bullet point no warning
and so this is on the top of the page
every page every single page of the 17
pages has it in bold print in capital
letters on the top warning
and then you go
to the actual um
uh validity scales because there's a
whole
validity of the test results now you
don't use any other validity
measures other than this validity
measure this is the validity measure
used by the test itself
so when you look at this and i'm on page
just
nine
remind the jury when you say the
validity of the results what does that
mean it means the validity of the
results that they found in this test
warning it may not be accurate so this
is the test that was given to michael
barissone and the test results indicate
the validity is questionable
more than questionable now when you put
warning on something that's to me that's
worth it quite insane results are
questionable take another look no they
said warning
and then they get into it on page nine
the last paragraph
the degree to which response styles may
have affected or distorted the report of
symptomatology on the inventory is also
assessed it means they're doing this
certain of these indicators fall outside
the normal range suggesting that
the respondent may not have answered in
a completely forthright manner the
nature of his responses might lead the
evaluator to form a somewhat inaccurate
impression of the client based upon the
style of responding below
and then it goes on the next page and
again this is in capital letters
the test results potentially involve
considerable distortion and are unlikely
to be an accurate reflection of the
respondent's objective clinical status
the following interpretation is provided
only as an indication
of the respondent's description
and then it goes on doctor in that same
paragraph is there anything in that
paragraph about malingli
um
well
yes
right above that it says with respect to
negative impression management
impression management is a word means
people try to manage their impression to
other people patients do it
defendants do it all the time
negative impression management is you
want to appear more disturbed than you
actually are positive impression
management is you want to appear less
disturbed than you actually are
so here
it says with respect to negative
impression management appearing more
disturbed
there are indications suggesting that
the client tended to portray himself in
an especially negative or pathological
manner
some deliberate distortion of the
clinical picture may be present
the critical item should be reviewed to
evaluate the possibility of malingering
and then it goes on
the important point is where is that in
his report i read his report and he said
the validity indicators are great and
here here we go that's not true i mean
come on now again i don't want to be
disrespectful and it's a little
uncomfortable doing it because someone
told me he's actually in in the
courtroom so i feel a little
uncomfortable doing it but uh anyway um
you know doctor let let me ask you you
just used the term uh malinger in there
yeah can you tell the jury what that
term means and where it comes from
faking an illness it's as simple as that
a a little boy doesn't want to go to
school because he didn't study for his
arithmetic test tells his mother he has
a stomach ache a person with a mental
disorder wants to feign mental symptoms
for obvious legal reasons
and without jumping ahead too far did
you find evidence in this case of
malingering in the defendant's case
i didn't find any evidence of the
lingering
i didn't find any evidence of lingering
the doctor
son did but didn't report it as such let
me let me maybe let me ask the question
a little more pointedly did you find any
evidence of malignant amnesia oh
malignant amnesia yes yeah not malignant
yeah yes i found malignant amnesia
absolutely but not malingering a mental
disorder can you explain the difference
between what you just uh answered and
what i had asked well
malingering generally means to malinger
an illness to maligner a disorder
malignant amnesia is different that's
when you claim you don't remember what
had been done but lingard amnesia um i
mean i can go into a lot of detail but
yeah that's that's
simply it can mean different things uh
in different situations malignant
amnesia means simply means only one
thing it means you're feigning loss of
memory that's what it means
doctor i want to direct your attention
at this point to some uh the last uh two
uh uh
tests that you gave to
michael barason can you tell the jury
what the t-a-t is the t-a-t is the
thematic appreception test this is an
old test from the 1930s it shows
pictures of
all sorts of
people in in ambiguous situations
and your job is to create a story and in
the process of the story hopefully
you'll reveal yourself and more
information about you will emerge just
give me a second
there is some
it should be fresh too if you need it no
i'm fine
um
i give the tit tik is not scored this is
a projective test
and you you you interpret it at the
level of face validity face validity
means on the face of it can you see can
you understand what's going on within
the person so for example if a patient
says there's a person leaning over a
couch crying thinking of suicide her
life is terrible this is the end
you've got a good idea of what's coming
from the person's mind you don't need a
score for that a scoring system
at all so i gave
michael that test and he gave ref he
gave themes involving depression despair
loss of hope inner conflict suicide
interpersonal loss
and significant inner turmoil there was
really nothing particularly outstanding
there's no question michael's depressed
it's just though there's no dispute in
my opinion anyhow
of that
did you also give him a projective test
well that was a projective test i gave
him another one called the projective
figure drawings this is a very simple
test you just ask people to draw a
picture of a house a tree
a person a person of the opposite sex
and the worst thing you could think of
usually you get nothing
not much like in this case you really
don't get much of anything
and what do you mean by that well
nothing really significant for example
so you ask a person to draw a picture of
a house because a house is very
important to people that's where you
live if you ever drove past a home that
you're um that you grew up in your
parents sold it and new people lived
there you get a funny feeling because
your ego boundaries extend beyond you to
your house so it's important tree person
opposite sex and worst thing you think
of usually you get not much but
sometimes you do
and i i gave the i don't know if what
would be an example of a significant
drawing well i i gave you some drawings
that i've included in a chapter that i
wrote and i have a lot of these in my
book of dismembered people exposed
genitals uh you know violence and this
sort of thing those are significant no
we didn't have it didn't have that here
you interpret it at a level of face
validity um
and
most competent people do that
now in dr hassan's report he refers to
referred to a number of people
which i thought was quite interesting
because a number of the people they
referred to as experts i not only know
these people i've worked with them about
four of them wrote forwards to my book
and he referred to one of my books he
referred to reed malloy who was a very
prominent person and he wrote a forward
to one of my books wrote a chapter in
another book and i wrote a chapter one
of his but i gave you an article i don't
know if this came out where he shows a
picture
a a a figure drawing that's very
illustrative which he put in an article
that he published so you know to say
that this isn't done is just incorrect
now doctor i want to ask you about your
particular uh diagnosis or conclusions
in this case and you had already
mentioned early on
the dsm right you mentioned that there
are different
editions uh over the course of time can
you just explain to the jury uh in your
own words what the significance of the
dsm is to your field well the the
diagnostic and statistical manual of
mental disorders is really the manual
that lays out the diagnostic criteria
for all of the diagnoses and they go
through different revisions the dsm-5 i
think was 2013 is the latest revision
but there'll be another one in a couple
years why because research comes in you
understand things more it's developing
it's evolving and so it changes it's
been around dsm-1 was published in 1952.
and this is the way you make a diagnosis
you use the criteria delineated and the
dsm now when i make a diagnosis in a
forensic case i do it with the manual
open
because who can memorize this nobody can
memorize this manual how are you going
to know
and so i do with the manual open and i
remember distinctly i said to michael
i'm gonna because sometimes people
wonder what are you bringing this big
book out for i said
i said i don't want to make a mistake
and i simply just going through all of
the criteria and evaluated him with all
the all the criteria all the diagnoses
that were raised in this case
you indicated that the dsm-5 is the
fifth edition
over the course of time what's your
understanding of how or the process that
goes into a new edition
uh coming out oh over the course of
let's say 10 15 years research is
published and the the dsm folks will put
together a committee on each different
diagnosis
they'll brainstorm as to what the
research tells us and then they'll make
modifications to try to keep everything
up to date and you know best practices
uh and so on
now you said that when you conducted
your examination of michael barissone
you were aware of dr simmering's
diagnosis yes
did you consider a number of diagnoses
in addition to what dr simran found yes
why did you do that because other
diagnoses were raised in the case and i
wanted to do a thorough job and make
sure i considered everything
what is what does the term psychosis
mean
psychosis simply means a break with
reality and it's manifested by symptoms
such as hallucinations and delusions
hallucinations are perceptual auditory
hallucination you hear voices visual
hallucinations you see things that
aren't there usually of religious
content
olfactory hallucinations you smell
horrible smells rotting flesh
gustatory hallucinations horrible tastes
in your mouth metal
um
tactile hallucinations bugs crawling
under my skin those are hallucinations
delusions
are false beliefs not based in reality
so for example
if you think two and two is six
that's not a delusion that's you're
incorrect
but if you think two and two is six
because martians change the number
system that's the delusion because
there's a break with reality that's a
bizarre delusion
now there's some non-bizarre delusions
that can actually occur
uh in daily life the difference being
martians is not an occurrence in daily
life but other things are and you could
develop a delusion so let me give an
example to illustrate a non-bizarre
delusion
i know of a case of a middle-aged guy
worked at a large company he was a
manager of like a a unit
and the company was going through some
sort of inspection or review
and he slowly developed an idea that the
administration of the company wanted
they were the company was going to fail
this reviewer inspection they were going
to blame him for it they're all plotting
now to blame him he'll lose his job
he'll never get another job and his life
will be completely destroyed
and when he said things similar to that
to his co-workers they said to him no
what are you talking about everything is
fine the the company's not going to be
uh
um
fail no one's trying to get rid of you
and his response was you don't
understand you just don't understand
that's very typical in the delusion the
people in your circle around you try to
dissuade you of this delusional belief
in that example you just gave was there
any
initial trigger for him having that
delusion
it was insidious it was insidious as to
why that happened but
all of that went on for an extended
period of time a couple of months he
became more and more
delusional with respect to this
conspiracy and what finally happened is
he's walking down the hall and the head
i guess the president or the head
administrator
said to him good morning doctor good
morning doctor good morning mr bailey
and that was it because he told his
friends he always called me bob
and today he called me mr bailey see you
see the you see the sign that's a
delusion that's a delusion that's a
non-bizarre delusion because i mean
people get fired from their jobs but
this was a break with reality
so that's essentially what a delusion is
a fixed false belief not based in
now
reality
we get to some of your uh diagnosis
doctor you indicated that you were aware
of dr simmering's diagnosis yes and uh
you're aware that he diagnosed the
defendant with delusional desert
disorder persecutory type and depression
disorder yes
with respect to depression disorder
would that affect a person's ability to
know right from wrong
generally no
would that affect a person's ability to
know
and appreciate the nature and quality of
their acts no generally no but i should
i should say i disagreed with dr simmery
with with respect to his diagnosis of
depression doctor explain that yeah dr
simmering diagnosed michael as having a
person a persistent depressive disorder
that's essentially a chronic low-grade
depression like a characterological
depression like a person who's like this
skeptic you know a downer i disagreed i
think he had recurrent
major depressive episodes and i based it
on
a number of factors including i read the
text messages from years ago with ann
picardo his long-term therapist and it's
way more than than persistent depression
so i disagree with dr simran with
respect to depression i think he had a
more significant
area of depression intermittently or
recurrently
with respect to the diagnosis of
delusional disorder
are you aware of the delusion that dr
simran identified
i'm not exactly sure of the delusion dr
simmering identified i
i mean he said it a couple different
ways it's not a hundred percent clear
he he all these texts met text not text
messages facebook postings that lauren
put on the internet
dr simmering asked him essentially
what do you think of those and he said
they were harassing and annoying and dr
simmering in his report said i disagree
with him they were coded messages where
he thought lauren was going to kill him
or so i think i i think that that that's
what he said but there was no
from when i read his report there was no
real clear delineation of what exactly
this delusion was
but
um anyway that's but there's no basis
for that at all well did you find any
evidence of delusions based on your
examination of michael bears no i found
i found no evidence of this at all and
here's what's important with respect to
a delusion this may have got
lost in the translation here
a delusion is not a fear if you're
frightened if you're terrified that is
not a delusion that's an emotional state
a delusion is a false belief not based
in reality and those in your circle try
to dissuade you of it like i mentioned
with the guy with the company
in this particular case
the people in his circle whether it was
mary haskins and or ruth cox they agreed
with him about lauren's dangerousness
if you listen to um mary haskins
interview with the police
you don't have to go beyond five minutes
she sits down she tells her what her
name is and where she's from and the
first thing she said is we're terrified
for our lives
is mary haskins delusional too
and at the end of mary haskins um
statement to the police you have to
listen to the very end because it's
about an hour or nothing she's just
sitting there in a room at the very end
she said
i don't know where i'm going to stay
tonight i can't stay at the farm because
lauren's father is going to come and
kill me
is that a delusion she's now delusional
look what ruth cox said ruth cox said
multiple times lauren is dangerous
lauren's going to not give up until she
gets what she wants
lauren is going to said to michael
lauren's going to set you up for sexual
assault because she knows it's not
defensible get her out of here she's
dangerous ruth cox is also dangerous you
mean everybody's delusional there
nobody's delusional there are they
frightened yes but that is not a
delusion that's not a break with reality
now
did you ask uh
michael barrasson about the pressure
that he was feeling
with respect to mr goodwin and ms
cantrack being at the property
yes i mean there was a long-standing
conflict there they had there was a con
there was an interpersonal conflict
between michael and and lauren
right from the beginning when they are
florida keep in mind they met in florida
lauren came from from
north carolina they met in florida there
was interpersonal problems in florida
they went to new jersey
more interpersonal problems they went
back to florida more interpersonal
problems at this point if you're so
delusional that a person's going to
going to kill you why do you let them
back to new jersey
they're down at that's a perfect break
time you're down in florida we're done
we're not doing any more training take
your horses put them in north carolina
but we're our training is over you
graduated or something like that why let
him back
he told me why he led him back he said
he needed the money he said
i was in under financial pressure um he
had a divorce going on he
you know he said
you have difficult clients everybody has
difficult clients you have to learn to
deal with it and and and so on
so he led him back so he wasn't that he
wasn't that frightened of her he wasn't
that terrified of her if you let her
back
did you ask him uh about the social
media posts
yes
and
did you review a number of those posts
yourself i reviewed all the social media
posts
of how did he characterize the posts
when you
interviewed well he told dr simmery
they're annoying and harassing
and that their dr sirmi thought they
were
coded messages
he thought that the manifesto was
killing the king was him and mary
haskins was the queen and there was this
all this conflict between them and
lauren's very i mean i don't i never met
lauren i know anything about lauren but
just to read these books she's obviously
very bright and very creative and um
she's writing all these things out in
symbolism and that's how he interpreted
it
i can see how he interpreted that that's
nothing distorted about it i see how he
interpret that i think it's very
reasonable interpretation
now moving ahead to uh closer in time to
the date of the shooting
uh did you ask michael barrasson about
when he first obtained ruth cox's gun
um yes but i have to refer to my report
somewhere because i'm not on page 47.
okay hold on for a second
um
[Music]
yes
um yes i asked him
what did he tell you about ruth cox has
done well
ruth said
in her statement that michael asked to
see her gun several days before the
shooting
and i asked him about that he said i
didn't ask to see your gun
and um he explained that ruth cox came
there on august 2nd and uh he he michael
knew she traveled with a gun
and he felt it wasn't safe in the car
with lauren there and um so uh ruth uh
gave me the gun and it went into safe
that that's what he told me
what's the significance uh if that
answer is accurate what's the
significance of that answer well the
significance is he had the gun and
that's the gun that was used in the
shooting
does it show anything with respect to
the nature and quality of his actions
does it show with respect to quality of
actions with respect to what
does it show anything with respect to
whether he appreciates or knows the
nature and quality of his eyes well you
know it certainly knows the nature and
quality of his axe what a gun is put it
in and put it in the safe of course
absolutely and
also the gun was in a case and the
ammunition was not loaded
dr ruth said that and michael said that
did you ask him about the when the town
came to the property
um
i believe that's on page 48 of your
report doctor
uh yes
um
i asked him about that i mean the fire
safety complaint is that what you're
referring to yes i asked him about that
and he said we had a house our home was
under construction minor issues and uh
goodwin turned it in
is there anything delusional about uh
anything with respect to that no not at
all why not just isn't it's all reality
based the goodwin did turn it in the guy
came they condemned part of the
residence and that was it all it all
actually happened this is not in his
mind this happened
now are there different types of
delusional disorder according to the dsm
yes
can a person with delusions know the
difference between right and wrong
depends on the case
can a person with delusions know the
nature and quality of their actions
usually yes
now moving on dr uh
and in the event i hadn't asked you this
just so i make sure i don't forget are
any diagnoses that you rendered within a
reasonable degree of psychological
certainty all of them that i rendered
now you already told us about your
diagnosis for depression
uh yes did you render a diagnosis
related to personality disorder yes
could you give me a page number council
page 64. 64. yes i did what is
personality disorder personality
disorder is everybody has a personality
and personality disorder is when the
traits are characteristic in one way it
it's it's simple as that um
i looked at him i i believe he has a
personality disorder um and i found that
the two traits that are most
characteristic of him are
obsessive-compulsive traits with a
preoccupation for detail order
organization and control devotion to
work inflexibility with respect to
morality and ethics and reluctance to
delegate to others i got this right this
is from the manual i'm not just making
that up i went right through the
criteria in the dsm and he meets the
criteria for that obsessive-compulsive
personality again it's not bad it's just
characterizing uh
the way he is a lot of successful people
have obsessive compulsive traits and i
also found deep feelings of inadequacy
i mean if you look at at this case in
its entirety inadequacy and low
self-esteem always emerges it comes out
it was certainly in and picardo's um
text messages and notes he said uh
you know and even in a text to mary
haskins he said i know i'm repulsive to
you as a man
and when i questioned him directly he
showed feelings of inadequacy as well so
i think the traits that best
characterize
michael are obsessed with impulsive
traits and inadequate traits
with respect to the personality disorder
diagnosis would that have affected his
ability to know right from wrong on the
day of the shooting no not at all would
it have affected his ability to know or
appreciate the nature and quality of his
actions no not at all
the last questions i'm going to ask you
about doctor you had referenced earlier
malingered amnesia yes and i know you
talked about this in your report on
pages 66 and uh 67 right can you remind
us what malignant ambiguity is
okay well malingering is simply faking
an illness
now the dsm is very it's very important
because what they say is and i'll refer
to this on page 66 of my report
um
the essential feature of malingering is
the intentional production of false
symptoms like memory loss
motivated by external incentives such as
this is
from the dsm evading criminal
prosecution and the dsm also notes that
malingering should be strongly suspected
not just suspected i think that's
possibly the only place in the manual
where they use the word strongly
suspected not consider it think about it
take a look at it no strongly suspected
if you have some of these factors
the individual is referred by an
attorney criminal charges are pending a
marked discrepancy between the
individuals claimed disability
and objective findings and observations
lack of cooperation in the evaluation
that didn't apply and in presence of
antisocial personality that didn't apply
but his claim disability is
uh
he claimed that he doesn't have memory
only for the criminal behavior
only for the cr his memory for
everything else is excellent are you
kidding day by day in some cases hour by
hour as to what happened
so
you know i considered first whether this
is dis
dissociative amnesia i just didn't jump
to a conclusion this is malignant
amnesia but i will say malignant amnesia
is very common in criminal cases
dissociative amnesia means means you
forget something and that can occur in a
trauma so i considered that
um
why didn't you diagnose that because i
don't think it's correct i think that
this is malingered amnesia uh for for
the reasons that i that i that i just
said you see
if you remem you have good memory like
he does
and the only thing you forget is
criminal conduct that's a red flag
because there's no memory disorder or
neurocognitive cognitive disorder that
is selective just for criminal conduct
so what does he not remember
getting the gun loading the gun driving
to where lauren was
initially hiding the gun under his shirt
asking for a goodwin to get lauren
lauren comes out he said to her are we
going to resolve this or do we go to war
and then he shot her twice
and then he has no memory for anything
else
until he said he wakes up at the
hospital with a big light on him and
people are touching his
you know his arm and his uh
head injury
but there's something very odd about
that first of all the only thing you
don't remember is the criminal behavior
why is that
why isn't every if it's a trauma why
isn't everything blocked out also when
you go to the hospital
now just think you you you go to a
hospital you don't have any remember a
memory of anything you wake up in the
hospital with a big light on you and the
staff are touching you the first thing
you say is
where the hell am i well what's going on
here why am i here he didn't say that he
didn't say that at all
and they asked him
what happened he said i don't remember
but what about the supposed delusion
that she was going to kill him that he
he didn't if he doesn't remember getting
the gun and shooting her
did he forget that he thought she was
going to kill him really he had so the
memory is not just for the criminal back
it's also for the supposed delusion well
why don't you say
i i i don't know i don't remember
anything but i know some woman's trying
to kill me that didn't happen that
didn't happen at all
doctor is there any difference between
malignant amnesia and feigned
immediately it's basically the same
judge may have a moment
sure
doctor was this was this shooting
difficult for you to understand shooting
is not difficult to understand it's a
very easy to understand case
judge i have no further questions at
this time
close examination
dr uh you currently have another case
with the morris county prosecutor's
office that you're
consulting on correct correct
now
in this particular case
you indicated that you spent a total of
13 hours
13.25 hours with regards to your contact
with my client correct yes and how much
of that 13 hours
was done
with testing
probably the first hour or two maybe
so you did about an hour or two of tech
testing
uh with regards to your evaluation
correct about that i mean you were there
i didn't i didn't time it but you were
there maybe you timed it
now
the rest of the time um
you basically
let michael
talk
about this incident correct well that's
probably not a completely accurate
description of what i did i let him talk
but it was response to my questions
so it wasn't just a free flow tell me
what you think i had a lot of pointed
questions okay now
um
the testing that you did
would you agree that uh
you did
the short version of a number of tests i
did the abbreviated version of the
wechsler uh intelligence test and i did
the standard first 370 basic questions
for the mmpi
now how many questions did you give for
the mmpi 370. and how many possible
questions
could you have given
well could i have given i would have had
to i would have to interpret this test
very differently that's about i don't
even know maybe 500 i don't even know
500 could be over 500 yeah
are you saying you don't know the exact
i don't know the exact number because i
don't give the complete version i give
the version that i give
now
in your discussions with uh
with michael
um
you indicated in your report that the
the problems the conflict with lauren
cataract started in
florida
in
2019 correct it was 2018 but i could be
i could be wrong
okay
if you refer to page four
you report
the fifth line down
is in effect you indicated on
around may of 2019
they returned to new jersey and then
later on mentioned that the conflict
between the parties
seemed to have begun in florida
the conflict began in florida i believe
it was 2018. if you look on page three
in the bottom um she was training in in
north carolina then lauren attended uh
the florida horse facility in the winter
of 2018
received training there two to three
months that's where conflicts began and
then
april began in 2018
yeah that's what i said in florida what
conflict oh interpersonal conflicts
there was interpersonal conflicts
respect of who was going to do the
training was it michael was it um was it
justin
the interpersonal conflicts and would
you agree that in may of 2019
uh things started to get worse the
conflict uh grew uh more severe correct
yes
so
without question
this conflict this stress
lasted
well over one month correct definitely
now
did you discuss with michael different
uh
things that he did
to try to protect himself and everyone
else at the facility
were you referring to something specific
council for instance like him um hiring
bugs yes he hired bug sweep hired a uh
a private investigator to do a criminal
background check on him yes
um and he also hired an individual by
the name of larry david to uh sit at the
top
of the
property
in front of the stable to protect the
people inside at night correct
now
you said you reviewed all these social
media posts yes how many of them were
there
i don't know estimate
thousands
tens of thousands i i i i
i don't know i got big binders maybe the
prosecutor has an exact
um okay what are your binders regarding
social media posts thick binders
how many binders i don't know how many
binders i can't remember multiple
binders when you say multiple do you
have any specific recollection of how
many social media posts you
look for i don't have a specific
recollection as to how many social media
posts except that i read all of them now
with respect to the number of binders
this ask them i i have them at home but
i didn't count them i don't i don't know
the exact number
now you'll agree with me that with
regards to the test
that you gave
there are people that uh question
the validity of all of these tests
we say there are people what do you mean
by that just a
group of people that if you want to
attack a test
there were people out there for every
single test that you gave
where people question the validity and
use of that test yes yes i would i would
answer it more precisely i would say
that's how science progresses
people do tests people do research they
question it and then you move on
and would you agree with me that this is
a a fluid of science
things change
the way tests give or given changes the
way tests are given are changes but some
some conclusions with respect to lack of
validity are definitive and it's and
it's conclusive
now
you didn't put in your report everything
that you reviewed
i could not do that i never do that i
say review the entire state's case
i i asked for the entire state's case
how many
video tape statements did you read
i reviewed all of them that i had how
many did you i don't remember what the
exact number is but let me think if i
could from my memory
um lauren's statement
the defendant didn't give a statement
justin hardin gave a statement ruth cox
gave a statement mary haskins gave a
statement defranco i
can't remember her name it's gave a
statement who else
um
i don't know if there may have been
another one i just can't recall it
offhand those are the major players
although defranco not that much
now
your position is that
and correct me if i'm wrong that
michael's
beliefs that lauren cataract was going
to kill him
mary haskins
and her children
is a rational
realistic fear oh i didn't say it was
rational and realistic but it's not
delusional it was based on what was
going on at the time
to be very very specific though council
with respect to his belief of of lauren
killing him that had absolutely nothing
to do with the shooting because at the
day of the shooting he said nothing
about that he said are we going to
resolve this or do we go to war and then
shot her there was nothing like you
think you're going to kill me i'll kill
you first or something where you usually
have in these sorts of confrontations
and it was triggered by the child
investigator coming
that's what triggered the whole thing it
wasn't triggered the day before by the
fire department coming it was triggered
by the by the investigator who wouldn't
be upset
if he he incorrectly thought that lauren
called child protection she didn't but
that's what he thought but but hold on
council
hold on hold on just ask another
question sometimes we get a little too
far afield doctor we got to reel it in
question answer answer counsel's
question don't deviate too much go ahead
ask another question
you're saying lauren cataract did not
call
dcpa
my understanding is that safe sport
called dccp that's why did you review
all of lauren cataract's text messages
yes
were you aware that she had googled
judge objection
did you uh
review review the social media post
where lauren cataract talked about going
to war
i don't have a specific recollection of
that statement but i reviewed the social
media post yes
do you have a specific recollection of
uh
reviewing posts where she accused him of
criminal conduct
online i don't i i know that that was
there was an accurate michael told me of
an accusation that she accused him of
insurance fraud
and animal abuse i think and and
something else so i'm aware of that okay
but you don't have a recollection of
reviewing those times
but his review of the document isn't
really an issue mr blancas i've been
saying that for a long time now
the issue is
what's in the defendant's mind right so
his statements
are what's pertinent so you should
characterize or ask questions aimed at
that issue
did michael tell you that he thought
that
lauren cataract
was dangerous
yes
now you indicated that other people on
the farm felt the same way yes um
would you agree with me that no one
felt that way to the extent that michael
barrison did well i would disagree to
the extent that mary haskins certainly
felt that because she said our life is
in danger and then she thought
additionally that lauren's father would
come kill her so that's pretty strong
and it's your
belief
that
those
beliefs of mary haskins were the
exact same
extent as what michael barrasson thought
i can't tell you i'm going to object
it's asking for state of mind of other
people yeah
based on not an interview with her but
on listening to an interview so
objection sustained
and
is it your belief that
those threats that michael barrasson
believed
had a
real rational basis for him to believe
them what threats
that she was going to kill him
mary haskins and the children this is
what he interpreted from the post this
this interpretation was supported by
mary haskins and ruth cox
now
did michael tell you that the reason
why he took the gun from
cox
was he believed it was unsafe to be in
the car because he was afraid lauren or
robert goodwin would break into the car
and get access to that weapon yes he
told me that and
do you believe that he was feigning when
he told you that no i don't believe he
was fainting i think you'd no the answer
is no
now
with regards to your opinion that
michael is
feigning amnesia as to not remembering
the event
would you agree with me
that during the incident
he was beaten about the head
no that was post incident that was after
the shooting he shot lauren twice shot
at goodwin goodwin
tackled him punched him in the head put
him in a choke hold and whatever else he
did that was afterwards okay and that
and that's that's according to your
review of the discovery correct just so
we're clear on the record yeah yes
correct
that comes from the statements of
goodwin and cataract correct
yeah that was that after the shooting
yeah he didn't hit him in the head
before the shooting irrespective of
when he received that beating would you
agree
that
a an extensive beating to someone's head
could cause
amnesia possible but not selective
amnesia
now would you agree with me that within
moments after the incident when the
police and the first aid people respond
that
michael barristone had indicated
virtually to every single person that
questioned him but mr belinkus
just if there's a specific
i don't i don't like when you make a
broad statement like that all right just
ask if if your recollection tied to the
evidence in the case all right go ahead
rephrase your question please are you
aware that with regards to the documents
that were provided to you that
immediately after the incident that
every single in a person that might wait
a second
am i talking to myself
you don't characterize it every single
person
i said tie it to a specific witness
you can go through each of the witnesses
i don't mind if you're doing that but
you can't just say everybody because i'm
not sure that was the testimony
doctor are you aware that with regards
to the first day people
that michael barrasso when asked
about the event
said he could not recall
anything concerning the event my
recollection is with the emt person he
made a statement that a person was going
to come to the farm and take my kids
away that's my recollection
and in addition to that that he had no
recollection of a specific event after
that
that's what he said to the ent people
after the shooting and before the police
came or as the police came he made
fatalistic statements uh i can't i have
it in my report but i can't recall
something like my life is over i had a
good life they took it all away
fatalistic statements those statements
indicate that he remembered what
happened because he didn't say what
happened what he didn't say arrest
goodwin he just attacked me
did any document that you read indicate
that when
they first arrived he was partially
conscious
yes did any document indicate to you
that he was incoherent
some did some did not did
hold on
counsel hold on a second hold on a
second just answer his question please
all right is it the fact that within
with respect to all the medical records
they indicated that he was confused and
he had an altered mental state some
medical records said that and the police
record said something different
and didn't one police report indicate
that at one point he says is this real i
need to wake up i believe he said that
in the ambulance
you're sure about that that's my
recollection i questioned him about that
and and it's in my report with respect
to uh with respect to that um
respect to that okay now
you're aware that michael barrison had
seen and picardo
over a 20-year period correct correct
did you ever talk to her no
i have nothing further
all right any um
you may step down thank you
all right any further witnesses on
rebuttal okay all right so the state
rest on rebuttal do you have one more
witness in server
let me see you at cyborg
ladies and gentlemen i'm going to
ask for your indulgence mr belinkus has
a what
he says in the prosecutor agrees will be
a short server butter witness as um as
we refer to it um we're going to try to
get it done today because um that is
going to be the last witness we'll
complete our testimony today
council and i have some legal matters to
go over tomorrow so you're going to have
the day off from this trial tomorrow
you're going to come back monday for
summations and charge
and then the liberations will follow
thereafter all right so we're going to
have one quick witness tonight and we're
going to get it done as quick as
possible it shouldn't be too long go
ahead mr belinkus
right left hand on the bible again
doctor please
please so in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony given to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
i do please state your name by your last
name for the record my name is charles
hassan h-a-s-s-o-n
all right you may have a seat doctor go
ahead mr malinkas dr hassan i'm going to
try to ask you some very
specific questions
and if you could
answer
as succinct and direct impossible
to say sometimes
you heard dr schlesinger testify with
regards to you scoring his test of the
mmpi correct yes
and why did you use his scores
it was an existing test i wanted
i wanted to compare his scores to my
scores and to see if there was any kind
of discrepancy okay and was there any
discrepancy well first of all
answer yes or no please no discrepancy
okay and what did you find with regards
to your
scoring using his data
on on which test the mmpi
found the very elevated score on the
scale
remarkably elevated skill 90. uh
scale 6 with a t-score of 90 which
suggests the deletional disorder
secondly i also found an elevation on a
scale that indicates
persecutory ideas
then i also scored other scales on there
that all point in the direction of a
delusion okay did you hear his testimony
basically saying that that score of 90
means nothing
well not what he said judge yeah that's
not exactly what he said that he didn't
agree with your interpretation of that
90 score did you hear his testimony yes
i heard that and what's your response to
that i think that uh he should be
uh he should be more familiar with the
literature on that test
now 500 questions 567
and as i
indicated earlier today
the particular person who uh
i referenced
james
butcher
he said that you should look up the
references in order to understand that
and i indicated the things from
nichols david nichols but basically i
can
totally
defend any position that a score of
so elevated score on scale sex is
indicative of a delusional disorder
right now with regards to his testimony
concerning the rorschach you heard that
correct may just add something this is
very important
in the book that was shown to me
yesterday by butcher
butcher said under no circumstances
should you play around with hand scoring
the test because it's too vulnerable to
make errors that was the reason i went
through the test a
second time rather than use his scores i
compared it
um
okay let's move to the rorschach okay
okay with regards to the rorschach
what if any problems did you identify
with regards to his administration of
that test well i don't know i don't
first of all he used a non-standard
approach which is remarkable to me he
did not indicate where the percepts were
located you have to open up the book to
find out where it's located he eyeballed
the data in my opinion
that is a violation of
being able to analyze tests in terms of
being reliable and valid
okay now with regards to the t-a-t
basically the t-a-t he eyeballed the
data
um
that test
does not have any error scores in there
there's no validity
reliability and the elephant in the room
that i saw was the fact that on two of
the cards there were weapons in there
one was a rifle and one was a handgun it
looked like and
mr barristone did not discuss that and
what does that mean to you well i mean
if you you accept the projective
hypothesis
that apparently uh dr schlesinger
applies into you ask yourself why
did the person ignore that is it part of
a dissociation where you look at the
environment and you see a stimulus you
don't see a stimulus because it's so
stressful to you
also
i'll try to keep it simple stupid
also there was very few responses on
that test
um there was just 14 responses also just
to
have everyone know
uh on on the rpas
and by mayer and the cs
trust me
those international norms
are not considered
valid i mean there's questions about it
there's a very low sample size on the
international laws laws and also on the
extra about 600 plus people on that
uh
the people they studied on the
international
okay
as far as the http test that he talked
about what
what's your
opinion as to how he did that a joke
it's eyeballing data anyone could come
up with an an opinion on that there's no
validity there okay doctor he says he
performed tests for about an hour to two
hours how long did you test michael
barrasso how many hours
i'd say maybe seven hours
and also to score
the rorschach
you're talking about two two and a half
hours
that's a highly in a difficult test to
score
all the data on the rpas group
comes from exname
the external system was incorporated
into the rpas system i don't know if uh
he is aware of that okay now finally
with regards to his comments concerning
you
administering the pai test
and him reading those things with the
you know warning sign on the top of the
page
what does that mean and how uh did you
interpret that simply i don't think he
knows the literature on terms of
validity testing he does not know
the literature from richard rogers i use
richards roger's cut scores
richard rogers and his group took into
account standard error of the
measurement if you give a test
for example
uh well okay let's go on
if you want me to uh stop
the uh bender gestalt test bendigo
gestual test is a joke in this kind of a
case bendicat test has
um false negatives that means i could be
brain damaged and do perfectly well on
that test
that's not a um an adequate test for
organicity how about the washi tape well
that's a joke too i'm sorry to say the
wassi test and the wechsler test you
know what they have in common the name
wexler
it is known
that the uh
wassi tesla will typically elevate
scores that's why your scores are higher
than my scores that's one of the factors
but that's known you should never give
the wassi test if you're looking to give
a a complete honest uh evaluation
nothing for everybody what
cross-examination
all right you may step down thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen thank you
for your patience
you've heard all the testimony in this
case you don't have any other uh sir
rebuttal witnesses do you mr belinkus no
no all right
you've heard all the testimony in this
case the next step will be
summations of counsel
and the charge by the court
we're not going to do that tomorrow for
a number of reasons number one uh
council and i have to review the charge
to make sure it's appropriate
and there are some legal issues that we
have to go over with regard to the
charge
and
the second reason is i don't want to
give you this case on a friday afternoon
late it's been two weeks of testimony
we're on schedule actually
um i i think we're doing better than
originally thought by council
so
i'd rather have summations monday when
everyone's fresh
i'll give you the charge you can have
the case monday and then tuesday and
however long you need next week
so we're going to um break for today
i'll meet with council tomorrow to go
over to charge we'll get that finalized
and we'll return monday morning fresh
nine o'clock as always for summations
and the charge all right it's important
now you've heard all the testimony so
please don't discuss the case with
anyone
and you'll have the case for
deliberation very shortly thank you all
we'll see you monday morning same time
[Music]
not the wrapper
[Music]
okay
you